foreign
come get a taste
[Music]
Rick where'd you get a hand grenade I
don't know hey there it's Nikki and
welcome to an extra exciting new episode
of RT Essentials but Nikki your episodes
are always super exciting oh my God
thanks I
agreed so much you flatter me no
honestly today is indeed special since
we're going to be discussing films that
feature ensemble cast because the more
the merrier except when it comes to this
show in which I hosted all by my
lonesome and also when it comes to Orcs
hold that thought these films are like
the All-Star games of Cinema so much
talent on display and more star power
than a James Webb Telescope Image Google
that now before we do this let's cover
the ground rules rule number one buy
Ensemble we made a cast that contains
three to four or more stars who share
somewhat equal screen time and narrative
importance
rule number two no touching of the hair
or face and that's it now let's do this
these are epic Ensemble casts
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King don't you let go
[Music]
don't let go
[Music]
a Monumental movie requires a Monumental
cast and the Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King is as Monumental as
it gets One does not simply walk into
Mordor not alone anyway it takes a team
consisting of wizards Hobbits dwarves
humans and elves director Peter Jackson
was under a lot of pressure when casting
the Beloved characters of J.R.R
tolkien's Classics everyone knows how
harsh book enthusiasts can be when it
comes to film adaptations and I am
looking directly at you Percy Jackson
fans at this point it's safe to say that
Jackson Peter not Percy found the right
players to bring tolkien's work to life
creating something magical something
fun we will find it now take it for now
for us yes
the cast of The Return of the King
includes Elijah Woods or Ian McAllen
live Tyler Kate Blanchette Vigo
Mortensen Andy Circus Orlando Bloom and
many others as is the case with many of
the other films on the list every single
one of these actors could be the main
attraction of any other feature but
their combined powers are otherworldly
Elijah Wood plays Frodo Baggins the most
unlikely creature imaginable a hobbit
tasked with being the ring bearer solely
responsible for the fate of Middle Earth
wood perfectly captured the characters
sensitivity and innocence and his dark
transformation as the Ring's power
consumes him Wood's performance is
complemented by the natural grid of
actors like Viggo Mortensen who plays
Aragorn a chosen member of the
fellowship sworn to protect Frodo on his
mission to destroy the ring not that
there is one clear standout on this film
but in mcallen's portrayal of Gandalf
the White wizard formally gray deserves
infinite praise but as powerful as
McKellen's Gandalf is we mustn't forget
the
Small Things everyday Deeds of ordinary
folk that keeps the Darkness at Bay that
and hitting Orcs over the head with a
wizard staff that certainly helps too
The Grand Budapest Hotel or maybe serve
you a gentleman
ah it's back to Hank by order of the
commissioner of police who broke a
province I hereby place you under arrest
for the murder of Madame Celine
Villanova Golf and taxis I knew there
was something fishy we never got the
cause of death she's been murdered
and you think I did it
hey Wes Anderson is known for his quirky
star-studded cats and The Grand Budapest
Hotel is no exception the film stars
Ralph finds Adrian Brody Saoirse Ronan
Tilda Swinton Owen Wilson Willem Dafoe
Jude Law Jeff Goldblum Jason Schwartzman
and many others not every director has
the ability to attract such talent over
and over again but Anderson isn't your
average director he's a no-too and
there's a reason why you'll often hear
people say that's so Wes Anderson of you
or say this is like a scene from a Wes
Anderson movie his films are known for
their planometric in symmetrical visual
Styles their intricate set designs and
their bold colors but let's be real we
come back for the characters no I don't
want to alarm you and I don't expect to
see any significant change in the
Magistrate's ultimate decision vis-a-vis
your own inheritance but especially
given the circumstances of the death as
well as The Disappearance of the key
witness in the murder case Serge X I
suggested we immediately bring this
matter to the attention of the municipal
inspector so there can be absolutely no
question of impropriety at any future
date agreed not agreed
not agreed in demand actors are often
eager to work with Anderson and for the
chance to portray one of his soon-to-be
iconic characters in fact for the Grand
Budapest Hotel Anderson reportedly got
his first choice for every role well
every role except one Murder She Wrote
icon Angela Lansbury was slated to play
the role of Madame D the hotel's wealthy
mysterious owner but she ended up having
to drop out due to other commitments so
Anderson turned to previous collaborator
Tilda Swinton I cannot imagine it any
other way Swinton had to layer on pounds
of makeup to achieve the look of the
Elder proprietor for the role of
Monsieur Gustav H the hotel's esteemed
Concierge in the film's main protagonist
Anderson sought out actor Ralph finds in
an unconventional way he emailed fines
letting him know he had written a script
for him to read and asked fine to let
him know which part he liked according
to Anderson this was a psychological
game because the best way to get an
actor to not want to be in your film is
to offer him a specific part needless to
say the game worked and fines agree to
the role and he chose the Gustav of
course this was very Wes Anderson of you
Wes Anderson Ocean's 11. with Benedict
no you're involved not know your names
or think you're dead because he'll kill
you and then he'll go to work on you
that's why we need to be very careful
very precise well funded yeah you got to
be nuts too
and you're gonna need a crew as nuts as
you are Steven soderberg's Ocean's 11
was a remake of the 1960 film of the
same name that featured the Rat Pack for
all of you youngsters out there The Rat
Pack was a group of entertainers that
starred in films and frequently
performed in Las Vegas the most notable
members being Frank Sinatra Sammy Davis
Jr and Dean Martin talk about an epic
Ensemble and big shoes to fill and tap
dance for the cast members of this film
but I'd say between George Clooney Julia
Roberts Brad Pitt Matt Damon Andy Garcia
Don Cheadle and Bernie Mac they pretty
much got by fine it should be illegal to
have that many really really
ridiculously good looking people in one
film
Lauren Wes Anderson Owen and Luke Wilson
were also meant to join the cast of
Ocean's 11 but the brothers had to pass
in order to fulfill their commitments to
the Royal Tenon bombs it wasn't just
them Mark Wahlberg also had to pass in
order to star in the Planet of the Apes
remake such a shame if only there had
been another movie that Wahlberg and
Damon could have starred in together
you know two Boston Heroes just
bostoning it up hmm
if only I wonder what that would have
been like
I'm afraid you're mistaken
your monitor
[Music]
this town your luck can change just that
quickly
find out how much money we have down
there for sure
in Ocean's 11 Clooney plays Danny ocean
who orchestrates the most sophisticated
elaborate Casino heist in history his
sidekick is Rusty Ryan played by Brad
Pitt and the two have an undeniable
on-screen chemistry though I have to
wonder if they wasted time on set
arguing over who's most handsome
actually it was cloudy who asked Pitt to
join the cast and now it's difficult to
imagine anyone else playing Rusty with
his insatiable appetite eating or
drinking something in almost every Scene
It was Pitt's idea to give Rusty that
character trait saying that the oceans
gang was on such a tight schedule his
character would have had to grab fast
food wherever he could okay Brad we know
you just like to eat in your movies The
Departed wow what is this of citizens
arrest blow me all right only one of us
is a copy of Bill you understand that
bill no one knows shut the [ __ ] up
massage it in the Massachusetts State
Police who the [ __ ] yo I erased you
who erased me huh yeah go ahead shoot a
cop Einstein Watch What Happens well
what happened is this bull would go
right to your [ __ ] head Watch What
Happens cue Dropkick Murphys The
depotted has shipped up our list of Epic
Ensemble casts the Scorsese film stars
Leonardo DiCaprio Jack Nicholson Alec
Baldwin Vera famiga Martin Sheen a bunch
of still microprocessors and Mark
Wahlberg and you guessed it
here it comes Matt Damon DiCaprio plays
Boston cop Billy Costigan who goes
undercover to infiltrate the
organization of mobster Frank Castello
played by Jack Nicholson Costello is
based on the real-life Irish gangster
Whitey Bulger who infamously ran the
Boston Winter Hill Gang committing a
series of crimes throughout the 60s and
70s for those unfamiliar with bulgery he
was second only to Osama Bin Laden on
the FBI's most wanted list and was
captured in 2011 after being on the run
for 16 years rumor has it that Bulger
snuck into a screening of The Departed
while he was still a fugitive and was
visibly disgusted by Nicholson's
fictional version of himself sorry
Bulger you're kind of on your own there
because critics and audiences
unanimously praised Nicholson's
performance and I certainly don't want
to make you mad but it is the truth I
got this red
annoying cheating all right
and it brings up questions
you know see Bill like you're the new
guy
girlfriend
why don't you stay in the bar that night
I got your numbers not to out shining
see what I did there Nicholson but
Wahlberg's performance as staff sergeant
Sean dignam earned him critical praise
and an Oscar nomination for best
supporting actor additionally Wahlberg
DiCaprio Nicholson were all nominated at
the Golden Globes though none of them
ended up winning acting accolades aside
when you put this much talent together
you get one of the greatest crime
Thrillers of all time this was
scorsese's first and only win for best
director isn't that Wicked ridiculous
and it came at a price roughly 50 of the
film's 90 million dollar budget was
spent on the actor's salaries hey we
said epic not affordable this is why we
always see Leo in the south of France in
the summertime X-Men Days of Future Past
I really think this will work I have
faith in him it's not a human mind about
it just We Were Young we didn't learn it
better
we will now
see also
This Might Sting a little
X-Men Days of Future Past is the fifth
installment in the X-Men film series and
features a plethora of legendary
characters that first appeared in Marvel
Comics much like Jackson's Lord of the
Rings adaptations and the filmmakers for
X-Men had to be extra careful when
casting such adored characters you don't
want the True Believers coming after you
although they're not quite as
unforgiving as Leaguers yes wisely my
friends pass wisely Days of Future Past
starred Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
Patrick Stewart and James McAvoy as
Professor X Michael Fassbender and Ian
McAllen as Magneto Jennifer Lawrence as
Mystique Halle Berry as storm Peter
Dinklage as Dr Bolivar Trask and far too
many others to list Azazel
Emma
thank you
brothers and sisters all dead
there's others experimented on butcher
Eric where were you Charles
we were supposed to protect them where
were you and your own people needed you
if you haven't seen the film you're
probably wondering why there are
multiple actors playing the same
character that's because the plot of
Days of Future Past involves Wolverine
going back in time and rallying the
X-Men of the past to help change a
pivotal moment in history and thereby
save the future Sir Patrick Stewart and
Sir Ian McKellen were performing in a
production of waiting for Godot when
they were asked to reprise their roles
as Professor X and Magneto as a lot of
Sir power for one Broadway play says
neither of the knights expected this and
were certain that the roles had been
permanently taken over by McAvoy and
Fassbender but it was a much welcome
surprise for the actors and there ended
up being undeniable camaraderie between
the older and younger Generations one
might even say their performances were
magnetic Anchorman the Legend of Ron
Burgundy
foreign
[Music]
boy
that escalated quickly
I mean that really got out of hand fast
you jumped up a notch it did didn't it
yeah I stabbed a man in the heart I
don't know how to put this but the next
ensemble cast is kind of a big deal
people know them they're very important
but seriously they are Anchorman the
Legend of Ron Burgundy was directed by
Adam McKay and stars Will Ferrell
Christina Applegate Paul Rudd Steve
Carell Fred Willard and David kochner
each of these actors are comedy Giants
in this film is an absolute riot from
start to finish there is literally a
riot too at one point more on that in a
sec Applegate plays Veronica
Corningstone a talented female
journalist in the male-dominated world
of 1970s Broadcast News Corningstone
starts to outshine burgundy feral on air
and a bitter Feud ensues resulting in
the downfall of burgundy's career I'm
Ron Burgundy You Stay classy San Diego
and thanks for stopping by but mainly
Stay classy thanks for stopping by
stay close
Applegate and Farrell have a hilarious
chemistry constantly throwing Jabs at
one another and flashing their comedic
shops in addition to starring Barrel
co-wrote the Anchorman screenplay with
McKay and the two had originally
envisioned a much different cast the
likes of which included Dan Aykroyd and
John C Reilly Stiller was originally
envisioned for the part of a ladies man
Brian fantana which ended up going to
Rudd but Stillers did still star in the
movie after all in one of the funniest
scenes in any movie ever the news team
fight also featured in this iconic
battle Vince Vaughn Luke Wilson and Tim
Robbins don't act like you're not
impressed Magnolia I want the
information that's what I want what did
you say because I am not going to take
care of him what does he want did he say
did he say what
what I want you to do Janet is I want
you to do your [ __ ] job
acclaimed filmmaker Paul Thomas Anderson
took inspiration from the music of Amy
Mann when he wrote Magnolia the film
consists of multiple plots and
characters from all walks of life
there's a dying father a young wife a
famous lost son a police officer in love
a game show host a boy genius and an
estranged daughter all of them
interrelated in some way when Anderson
started working on the script he had
specific actors in mind that he would
write for and envision certain sequences
and images that feature said actors one
of the first images that came to him was
the face of actress Melora Walters
followed by an image of her father
played by Philip Baker Hall both of whom
ended up starring in the film
I'm sort of giving away the answer here
but that's it's Chopin I don't mean to
give away the answer it's it's just
please just you know
sing us a diddy guys the Chopin Diddy
let's have a Chevy
[Music]
car go to the cart
Anderson has always been a Visionary so
it's not surprising that actors were
eager to work with him and in addition
to Walters and Hall this ensemble cast
included Tom Cruise Melinda Dillon
Philip Seymour Hoffman Ricky J Julianne
Moore Alfred Molina John C Reilly
William H Macy and several others and a
bunch of frogs by the way I didn't
forget that scene terrified of frogs
Crews had become a fan of Anderson after
seeing his previous film Boogie Nights
and asked the director to keep in mind
for future roles when Anderson finished
the Magnolia script he sent it to Cruz
who eventually agreed to the park I'm
sure he's glad he did because the role
earned him an Oscar nomination for best
supporting actor and a win in the same
category at the Golden Globes
The Dark Knight
foreign
's Dark Knight was the sequel to Batman
Begins and starred Christian Bale as
Batman Sir Michael Kane as Alfred
pennyworth Heath Ledger as the Joker
Gary Oldman as Gotham Police Officer
James Gordon Aaron Eckhart as Harvey
Dent AKA Two-Face Maggie Gyllenhaal as
Rachel Dawes and Morgan Freeman as
lucious Fox it goes without saying but
bail almost never misses and his
portrayal of Batman is certainly a fan
favorite also Sir Michael Kanis he's Sir
Michael Kane but it was Heath Ledger's
portrayal of the Joker that still stole
the show now I'm not one to play
favorites but the late actor delivered a
truly haunting performance one that made
this film's Joker one of the greatest
villains in any superhero release to
date does Harvey know about you and his
little bullying
killing is making a choice
between one life or the other your
friendly district attorney right
you have nothing nothing to threaten me
with nothing to do with all your
strength Ledger's Joker was the perfect
rival to Bale's Batman two of the
all-time greats hero and villain pushing
themselves to the brink both physically
and emotionally for their roles Nolan
was very aware that there would be
comparisons between Jack Nicholson's
popular joke of portrayal and that of
ledgers and many believe Ledger wasn't
even a bright fit for the park but Nolan
did not budge and although Ledger was
originally reluctant he admitted that he
had found the challenge exciting for his
portrayal Ledger won an Oscar for best
supporting actor posthumously Pulp
Fiction we should have shotguns with
this kind of deal
got me up there three or four that's
counting that guy
not you
so that means it could be up to five
guys up there it's possible
we should have shotguns Quentin
Tarantino's Pulp Fiction became an
instant classic with many now
considering it to be a masterpiece
Tarantino has always possessed an
ability to surround himself with serious
talent and create character-driven films
that cement themselves in pop culture
considering this was only Tarantino's
second film ever a fact that is hard to
process it's that much more impressive
that he was able to round up this cast
which included John Travolta Samuel L
Jackson
Uma Thurman Bruce Willis Tim Roth Ving
Rhames and many others I'm here to help
if my help's not appreciated lots of
luck gentlemen no no no Mr Wolf it ain't
like that your help is definitely
appreciated listen I don't mean
disrespect okay I respect you I just
don't let people barking orders at me
that song from Kirkwood it was because
time is a factor I think fast I talk
fast and I need you guys to act fast if
you want to get out of this
so pretty please with sugar on top clean
the car if for some reason you're unsure
of what makes this cast so special look
no further than the scene where Mia
Wallace and invega Thurman and Travolta
go out for a bite to eat and end up
doing the twist during an impromptu
Dance Competition I'm sure you've
witnessed at least one couple recreating
this scene every Halloween party since
the film's release and a few hosts
understandably so it's that iconic
furthermore Pulp Fiction was largely
responsible for breathing new life into
Travolta's career which had been on the
decline good for Danny Zuko just gonna
gloss over that whole Battlefield Earth
situation Avengers end game Avengers
Assemble
last but certainly not least is Avengers
end game any Avengers film or superhero
film really is bound to have an epic
ensemble cast but this one had to be
particularly epic I mean we're talking
about the final showdown with Thanos you
know the evil demigod who decimated the
planet most of the universe with a snap
of his fingers obviously they had to
call in the big guns drum roll
please Robert Downey Jr Chris Evans
Scarlett Johansson Chris Hemsworth Mark
Ruffalo Don Cheadle Jeremy Renner Paul
Rudd Ray Larson John Favreau Karen
Gillen Benedict Wong Bradley Cooper
Gwyneth Paltrow and of course Josh
Brolin as Mr blip himself Thanos it's
like the Avengers of actors thought by
eliminating half of life
the other half would thrive
but you've shown me
that's impossible
and as long as there are those that
remember what was there will always be
those that are unable to accept what can
be not too shocking to hear that end
game was one of the most expensive films
ever made but also became the highest
grossing film of all time
for a few years anyway so there's that
there are way too many outstanding
actors in the film to focus on just one
but according to co-director Joe Russo
Robert Downey Jr AKA Iron Man might have
been the only one to read the entire
script so I think he deserves a shout
out for just that well that concludes
our list of Epic Ensemble casts as is
always the case we didn't have time to
cover every worthy Ensemble ever to hit
the big screen but there are plenty of
new episodes of RT Essentials coming
your way so I'm sure we'll get there
eventually thanks again for tuning in
I'm Nikki Novak Farewell My Brave
cinephiles my work is now finished here
at last on the shores of the Sea comes
the end of our episode
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]